Fans said your eyes
How can it be so good?
The text is so small
You see everything very clearly.
The reason I am able
Reading small print effortlessly
It's because I have
Secrets to eye care
And after doing this secret...
can also help you
Improve presbyopia and myopia
And eye strain
If you learn it
Absolutely beneficial for a lifetime
Hu Naiwen is about to begin his lecture.
I am your old friend, Dr. Hu.
A 70-year-old can read small print very clearly
5 acupoints to treat presbyopia and myopia
Come , I'll tell you right away.
I'll be 70 years old.
The secret to not needing reading glasses
That's the move.
Roll your hands up like this
Oh, beautiful lady
Will you do it with me?
OK
Roll your hands up like this
Then place it on your eye socket.
There are several acupoints
Zǎn zhú (transliteration)
Yú yāo(transliteration)
Tóng zǐ liáo(transliteration)
Chéng qì(transliteration)
Jīng míng(transliteration)
Just these few acupoints
Often like this
rub, rub, rub
Just rubit like this
Just rub it like that.
How long should rub?
About one or two minutes
Two or three minutes is fine
Let's press it again.
Here, the eyebrows
Zǎn zhú (transliteration)
Yú yāo(transliteration)
Then come to the edge
Tóng zǐ liáo(transliteration)
And under the eyes
This is called
Chéng qì(transliteration)
Additionally, on both sides of the nose
inner side of the eye
This is calledJīng míng(transliteration)
That's it
Do it once, then twice, then three times.
Because it hurts a little
So don't do it for too long.
Just
doing it briefly
I'm telling you
Your eyes in the future
It's about the same as mine.
The Yellow Emperor's Inner Classic says
Wǔ zàng liù fǔ zhī jīng qì(transliteration)
Jiē shàng zhù yú mù(transliteration)
It means yourjīng qì(transliteration)
Your Qi and Blood
All of them will be supplied to the eyes
Therefore, the condition of your eyes
also reflects the condition of your body.
If you for a long time
Staring at the screen or looking at stocks
eyes are sore from looking at it.
Quickly massage
this area once or twice
just like that.
People who already have presbyopia
You can also improve your eyes
through massage
The cycle of this place
It can also slow down the aging
and degeneration of your eyes.
Awesome!
You can teach
your grandparents, parents
and other family members at home.
The whole family massage it together
the best natural eye remedy
A small handful every day
5 days to combat dry eyes
Beautiful wife, do you know?
People with dry eye in Taiwan
There are six million people
It means that in the office
There are 2-3 people
out of 10
eyes are dry and itchy.
need to use eye drops every day
Only then!
I'm telling you
There is a great
natural eye remedy
Relieve dry eyes
in just one week
It's goji berries.
Studies confirm that healthy middle-aged people
Eat 5 days a week
1 small handful at a time
Take that for 90 consecutive days
macular pigment density
Immediately
Significant increase
And the effect of protecting the retina
It's even better than
taking supplements
Animal experiments
All of this has proven
Consuming goji berry extract
Its tears will also increase.
Corneal damage has also decreased
It even improved dry eye syndrome.
What's the most effective way to eat goji berries?
I'll teach you two tricks.
First trick: Eat it as a snack for office workers.
It's the most convenient!
Grab a few goji berries and slurp them down.
Eat it as a snack
inside the mouth
It doesn't feel uncomfortable
It can relieve dry and tired eyes.
Someone will definitely ask
How many goji berries can eat a day?
Eat a small handful
Maybe around a dozen to twenty or so
The second method: Steep goji berries, chrysanthemum, and cassia seeds together.
Goji berries, cassia seeds, chrysanthemum
brew them together and drink
Helps improve blood circulation in the eyes
can feel it within a week
Eyes became bright and watery
Very comfortable
When buying cassia seeds
There is a secret
I suggest that when you’re buying it
at the Chinese herbal medicine shop
Buy half raw and half stir-fried
Raw and stir-fried
Why?
Because raw food
can xiè yī diǎn diǎn huǒ (transliteration)
It's also good for helping with bowel movements.
Because this bù róng yì shàng huǒ (transliteration)
It can also improve blood lipids
Helps improve blood circulation in the eyes
Next, we'll ask xiǎo fēn (transliteration) to demonstrate how to brew it.
Goji Berry, Chrysanthemum, and Cassia Seed Tea
Let's make some
goji berry, chrysanthemum, and cassia seed tea.
There are three types of materials to prepare.
5 grams of goji berries
3 grams of chrysanthemum
5 grams of cassia seeds
You put all the ingredients
into a cup or teapot.
Pour in another 300-500cc of hot water.
Steep for 15 minutes
can drink it
How do you tell
good goji berries from bad ones?
Most important
Don't just look at this one thing.
Look at its stem end.
Is this stem end exactly the same color
as the goji berry?
You shouldn't buy this.
That's the dyed one.
Goji berries have an orange color, right?
And what about the stem end on the top?
It should be lighter than its color.
Somewhat white
That's not dyeing.
It is naturally like that.
And that one that's too red and too beautiful
It might even smell a little sour.
Then don't buy it.
Choose products with large granules that are pesticide-free.
No preservatives
No pigment
It’s organically certified.
Eat with peace of mind and for effective results
Not a mobile phone
2 habits
Causes children's myopia to skyrocket
Some mothers said
She won't let the kids use their phones anymore.
Why still nearsighted?
The main cause of nearsightedness
Not a screen
Instead, it involves prolonged close-range use of the eyes.
Like watching TV from less than 3 meters away
Or the distance is less than 30 centimeters
Writing and reading
These are the real reasons
why your eyes
can't take it.
Children are prone
to nearsightedness
often due to two habits.
How to hold a pen
Reading posture
Let's start by talking about how children hold a pen.
How do childrenwrite it
We see children now
When was very young
and then start learning to write
Probably in kindergarten
Or perhaps only three or five years old
Mom said
Take a pen and draw a picture.
Write a word.
You know that children's hands are not strong.
Pick up pen
That's how make it powerful.
Write it like this
When written like this
You can't see with your eyes
so what
You have to tilt your eyes
like this to look
If
You can change this habit.
Just write like this
But children don't have the strength.
That’s what it looks like when he picks it up
In that case
Look at the drawing
too closely
What was written
What else?
When was studying
Sometimes head gets tired.
Reading like this
If you read like this
The eyes became skewed.
yes or no
too close to that piece of paper
When I was little
My dad taught me to write.
The light came down
from the left front like this.
Then he told me
This head must be like this
Write it like this
Your eyes should be at the distance between the words
Approximately 25-30 cm
That's better.
So I've been like this until now.
They all benefited from this
So
if you have a young child
at home
You should learn from me.
When he turns 80
Still have very good eyesight
One movement to relax the ciliary muscle
to prevent your nearsightedness
from skyrocketing
Beautiful wife
You know, kids these days
are getting nearsighted at increasingly younger ages.
yes or no
yes
Nearsighted children in kindergarten
It's almost 10%.
One in ten people
When was in first grade
It surged to 20%.
It was even more exaggerated in sixth grade.
Up to 70%
Nearsighted at such a young age
also need to wear glasses
This isn't too sad.
Come on
I'll teach you a simple method.
Prepare a pen
Like this on my hand
There is a pen
You're holding this pen.
Practice looking at things from afar and up close.
Do you know how to do it?
Is this pen
clearly visible here
very clear
Then slowly, slowly, they pull away.
And must be able to see it very clearly.
See very clearly
Then when zooming in...
You can see it very clearly, right?
The focus is
always on this pen.
Then zoom in, zoom in, zoom in.
zoom in to the nearest position
Let's pull it a little further away.
Then gradually pull away
Gradually pulling away
You often practice like this
can watch it forever.
to look at things from a certain distance
This will make it less likely
for your eyes to become nearsighted
Do the pen tip near and far distance training
we just talked about.
Like giving your eyes
a stretch
It straightens out for a moment, then relaxes
Straighten for a moment, then relax.
In that case...
It made the eyes do
Stretching exercises
Relax stiff muscles
This makes the ciliary muscle very flexible.
Your eyesight won’t worsen rapidly.
Even people who are already nearsighted
You often do this kind of training
It's also very good.
Our editor is nearsighted with a prescription of 500 degrees.
He also used this kind of training time
It's been almost a year.
He could see the distance much more clearly than before.
Let's go play
Badminton and Baseball
The eyes kept looking back and forth
Is that also possible?
certainly
Research shows...
An extra hour of outdoor exercise per week
The risk of myopia is reduced by 2%.
On the contrary
Scrolling through your phone for an extra hour each week
How much do you know about the risks of myopia?
That's an increase of 6 percentage points.
so what
Take grandson outdoors
for some exercise
This is the best way to prevent nearsightedness
It's not just that eyes have gotten better.
relationship has become closer
One thing and two things
Kill two birds with one stone
Hahaha
Is my Taiwanese accurate?
Drinking instant coffee can damage your eyes.
Eat less of these 3 types of food
Let me tell you...
There is something that can hurt your eyes.
It's instant coffee.
We used to eat a lot of instant coffee.
good
Research shows that...
said people who are used to drinking instant coffee
Risk of macular degeneration
How much taller than the average person?
Did you know?
7 times
ah
Instant coffee can hurt eyes
In the manufacturing process of instant coffee
Two harmful substances will be produced
Acrylamide and the end products of saccharification
They can cause oxidative stress in the retina.
Chronic inflammation
Over time, this can easily lead to the degeneration of eye cells
And in Taiwan
Macular degeneration is actually quite common.
People over 65 years old
About one in ten
So people who love instant coffee
suggest you don't
Drink every day
Besides instant coffee
These 3 foods can also harm your eyes.
Type 1 High-sugar foods
Accelerating eye aging
Damage to blood vessels
The second type of high-fat food
Increases blood viscosity
Blood circulation in the eyes will become poor.
The third type is cold food.
Ice cream, sashimi, etc.
Traditional Chinese medicine believes that eating ice cream is bad.
Let's use our current perspective.
To put it another way
It can constrict blood vessels and impede blood circulation.
Poor blood circulation
Keep eyes from gettinghán liáng (transliteration)
Very important
I also use steam eye masks.
Come and relax my eyes.
The second step is the method of supplementation.
To protect your eyes
you can eat foods containing lutein and astaxanthin.
What foods contain lutein?
Like dark green vegetables
For example, spinach, broccoli
Helps you absorb blue light
Protect your macula
Foods containing astaxanthin
For example, salmon, shrimp, etc.
These seafood
Eliminate eye fatigue and provide antioxidants
It's not just about not using your phone
It's not just about not looking at things up close.
You need to be careful even about the food you eat!